good morning world I feel like making a
youtube video today there used to be a
time in my life when making YouTube
videos was the thing that I did instead
of working but very gradually as this
YouTube thing has become my job I now
find myself doing pretty much anything I
possibly can to avoid it and it's not
like I'd only enjoy making videos
anymore or anything like that it's just
that I find it quite hard to get started
[Music]
my current top 5 methods of
procrastination in no particular order
are number one being really really
thorough when I'm doing the dishes of an
attempt to make the process lasts as
long as I possibly can number two giving
myself a tea break when I don't deserve
to have a tea break
also sometimes I eat biscuits nor remove
doing my taxes early in order to get
them out of the way no seriously what
most people will avoid having to do
their taxes I will use my taxes as a
method of procrastination yes I am crazy
number four replaying portal 2 on my
xbox even though I've already completed
it on my Mac for no reason other than to
get the achievements on the Xbox even
though I've already gotten them all on
my Mac and finally number 5
[Music]
juggling so much good now this is where
things get serious these are my er these
are my serious glasses procrastination
is something that everyone has to deal
with but the amount that you
procrastinate can actually be load so
long as you know a little bit about how
the whole thing actually works when you
procrastinate to individual parts of
your brain are essentially battling out
with each other the first part is called
the prefrontal cortex which you'll find
about here and this is the part of the
brain that does the I really need to get
some work done today or ask my boss is
gonna be really mad with me type of
thinking and the second part is called
the limbic system which I would point to
but it's quite a primitive part of the
brain and is therefore buried quite deep
inside of my head and this is the part
of the brain that does the art I should
check my emails oh I wonder what's on TV
ha I should take in that Oh a chocolate
chip cookie type of thinking the problem
lies in that although your prefrontal
cortex can see the long-term benefits of
you getting some work done it also gets
tired really easily whereas the limbic
system is much more powerful it's
directly connected to your brains
pleasure Center and it only really cares
about things that give you immediate
satisfaction and that essentially is
what you're battling against the
immediate satisfaction of say playing
video games versus the long-term
satisfaction of actually being
productive so what can we do surely
well the limbic system gets more
powerful whenever any temptation that
you have to do something other than work
becomes more tangible ie you can hear it
or you can smell it or you can see it
for example the temptation to check your
email becomes more tangible when you
hear that little sound telling you that
you have new mail so if you want to make
that temptation to check your email less
tangible you turn off that little email
notification sound similarly if you have
a temptation to watch YouTube videos
when you're meant to be working yes I'm
looking at you then maybe turn off your
internet until you're done with your
work I mean yes it's fine to go and
watch youtube videos and stuff but see
if you can find a natural break in your
productivity to go and do so instead now
obviously I can't spell out to you all
of the practical solutions for all
different forms of procrastination that
you specifically have because
everybody's temptations are different
but the formula to reducing the amount
that you procrastinate is to work out
what your temptations are to reduce the
tangibility
of those temptations somehow and then
you'll
hibbett your limbic system and you
hopefully won't procrastinate as much
that is the best that I can do I hope it
helps you a little bit I hope you
understand procrastination a bit better
now and I hope that you good bye these
things always have slightly awkward
endings don't be you've just had the
almost imponderable joy of watching
Charlie is so cool like which makes you
like cool